[Music]
in the last video along with the ideas
of vector addition and scalar
multiplication I described Vector
coordinates where there's this back and
forth between for example pairs of
numbers and two-dimensional vectors now
I imagine the vector coordinates were
already familiar to a lot of you but
there's another kind of interesting way
to think about these coordinates which
is pretty Central to linear algebra when
you have a pair of numbers that's meant
to describe a vector like 3 -2 I want
you to think about each coordinate as a
scalar meaning think about how each one
stretches or squishes vectors in the XY
coordinate system there are two very
special vectors the one pointing to the
right with length one commonly called
ihat or the unit Vector in the X
Direction and the one pointing straight
up with length one commonly called J hat
or the unit Vector in the y
direction now think of the x coordinate
of our Vector as a scaler that scales IH
hat stretching it by a factor of three
and the y-coordinate as a scaler that
scales J hat flipping it and stretching
it by a factor of two in this sense the
vector that these coordinates describe
is the sum of two scaled vectors that's
a surprisingly important concept this
idea of adding together two scaled
vectors those two vectors IH hat and J
hat have a special name by the way
together they're called the basis of a
coordinate system what this means
basically is that when you think about
coordinates as scalers the basis vectors
are what those scalers actually you know
scale there's also a more technical
definition but I'll get to that
later by Framing our coordinate system
in terms of these two special basis
vectors it raises a pretty interesting
and subtle point we could have chosen
different basis vectors and gotten a
completely reasonable new coord system
for example take some Vector pointing up
and to the right along with some other
Vector pointing down and to the right in
some way take a moment to think about
all the different vectors that you can
get by choosing two scalers using each
one to scale one of the vectors then
adding together what you get which two
dimensional vectors can you reach by
altering the choices of
scalers the answer is that you can reach
every possible two-dimensional vector
and I think it's a good puzzle to plate
y a new pair of basis vectors like this
still gives us a valid way to go back
and forth between Pairs of numbers and
two-dimensional vectors but the
association is definitely different from
the one that you get using the more
standard basis of ihat and jhat this is
something I'll go into much more detail
on later describing the exact
relationship between different
coordinate systems but for right now I
just want you to appreciate the fact
that anytime we describe vectors
numerically it depends on an implicit
choice of what basis vectors we're using
so anytime that you're scaling two
vectors and adding them like this it's
called a linear combination of those two
vectors where does this word linear come
from why does this have anything to do
with lines well this isn't the atomology
but one way I like to think about it is
that if you fix one of those scalers and
let the other one change its value
freely the tip of the resulting Vector
draws a straight
line now if you let both scalers range
freely and consider every possible
Vector that you can get there are two
things that can happen for most pairs of
vectors you'll be able to reach every
possible point in the plane every
two-dimensional Vector is within your
grasp however in The Unlucky case where
your two original vectors happen to line
up the tip of the resulting Vector is
limited to just this single line passing
through the
origin actually technically there's a
third possibility too both your vectors
could be zero in which case you'd just
be stuck at the
origin here's some more terminology the
set of all possible vectors that you can
reach with a linear combination of a
given pair of vectors is called the span
of those two
vectors so restating what we just saw in
this lingo the span of most pairs of 2D
vectors is all vectors of 2D space but
when they line up their span is all
vectors whose tip sit on a certain
line remember how I said that linear
algebra revolves around vector addition
and scalar multiplication well the span
of two vectors is basically a way of
asking what are all the possible vectors
you can reach using only these two
fundamental operations vector addition
and scalar
multiplication this is a good time to
talk about how people commonly think
about vectors as points it gets really
crowded to think about a whole
collection of vectors sitting on a line
and more crowded still to think about
all two dimensional vectors all at once
filling up the plane so when dealing
with collections of vectors like this
it's common to represent each one with
just a point in Space the point at the
tip of that Vector where as usual I want
you thinking about that Vector with its
tail on the origin that way if you want
to think about every possible Vector
whose tip sits on a certain line just
think about the line
itself likewise to think about all
possible two-dimensional vectors all at
once conceptualize each one as the point
where its tip sits so in effect what
you'll be thinking about is the infinite
flat sheet of two-dimensional space
itself leaving the arrows out of
it in general if you're thinking about a
vector on its own think of it as an
arrow and if you're dealing with a
collection of vectors it's convenient to
think of them all as points so for our
span example the span of most pairs of
vectors ends up being the entire
infinite sheet of two-dimensional space
but if they line up their span is just a
line the idea of span gets a lot more
interesting if we start thinking about
vectors in threedimensional space for
example if you take two vectors in 3D
space that are not pointing in the same
direction what does it mean to take
their
span well their span is the collection
of all possible linear combinations of
those two vectors meaning all possible
vectors you get by scaling each of the
two of them in some way and then adding
them together you can kind of Imagine
turning two different knobs to change
the two SC scalers defining the linear
combination adding the scaled vectors
and following the tip of the resulting
Vector that tip will Trace out some kind
of flat sheet cutting through the origin
of three-dimensional space this flat
sheet is the span of the two vectors or
more precisely the set of all possible
vectors whose tips sit on that flat
sheet is the span of your two vectors
isn't that a beautiful mental
image so what happens if we add a third
vector and consider the span of all
three of those guys
a linear combination of three vectors is
defined pretty much the same way as it
is for two you'll choose three different
scalers scale each of those vectors and
then add them all
together and again the span of these
vectors is the set of all possible
linear
combinations two different things could
happen here if your third Vector happens
to be sitting on the span of the first
two then the span doesn't change you're
sort of trapped on that same flat sheet
in other words adding a scaled version
of that third Vector to the linear
combination doesn't really give you
access to any new
vectors but if you just randomly choose
a third Vector it's almost certainly not
sitting on the span of those first two
then since it's pointing in a separate
Direction it unlocks access to every
possible three dimensional Vector one
way I like to think about this is that
as you scale that new third vector it
moves around that span sheet of the
first two sweeping it through all of
space another way to think about it is
that you're making full use of the three
freely changing scalers that you have at
your disposal to access the full three
dimensions of
space now in the case where the third
Vector was already sitting on the span
of the first two or the case where two
vectors happen to line up we want some
terminology to describe the fact that at
least one of these vectors is redundant
not adding anything to our span
whenever this happens where you have
multiple vectors and you could remove
one without reducing the span the
relevant terminology is to say that they
are linearly
dependent another way of phrasing that
would be to say that one of the vectors
can be expressed as a linear combination
of the others since it's already in the
span of the
others on the other hand if each Vector
really does add another dimension to the
span they're said to be linearly
independent
so with all of that terminology and
hopefully with some good mental images
to go with it let me leave you with a
puzzle before we go the technical
definition of a basis of a space is a
set of linearly independent vectors that
span that
space now given how I described a basis
earlier and given your current
understanding of the words span and
linearly independent think about why
this definition would make
sense in the next video I'll get into
matrices and transforming space see you
then
[Music]